the pac-12 is balling right now
brody goes to work man denied by mobley
brody gets it back tonight again
coming into the tournament all we ever
heard about was the big ten the big 12
and the acc
but it's the pac-12 that represents a
quarter of the men's sweet 16
field no one expected this no one
predicted this
but it's about damn time the pac-12 shot
the conference of champions has been a
laughingstock under commissioner larry
scott
winning zero football in men's
basketball championships
since its expansion the pac-12 simply
hasn't performed to the same level as
other power five conferences in these
sports
despite the influx of talent on the west
coast as an arizona state alum
even though my school isn't involved in
the madness it's been refreshing to see
the pac-12 destroy
all of our brackets i mean who would
have thought oregon state would make it
further than illinois in the midwest
region
you've got oregon now who's made the
sweet 16 five
times since 2013 and we finally got usc
and ucla living up to their names the
pac-12 needed one of these moments to
rejuvenate the fan base and put the
country on notice
so here's to more pac-12 chaos in march
baby